make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
[Music]
what's going on guys this is rob and i
realized about five minutes ago that you
can replace batman with rob core in the
old adam west batman theme song
and it's amazing but how's everybody
doing right how's everybody doing uh so
we are covering the guardians of the
galaxy tie-in
for the king and black and it kind of
makes sense right the king of black
events touching everything and i was
kind of wondering when we were going to
get to this right now in fact it was
actually one of you guys who suggested
that i cover it because
at first i was kind of like i mean is it
going to expand beyond the universe and
i have been paying attention
to guardians of the galaxy for a while
i've been glossing over it but i haven't
really been like
reading it with any real measure of
thought and uh and one of you guys
suggested us i was like okay cool we'll
check it out and it's cool because we're
only 10 issues in right this is the 10th
issue so if you guys want to see me
cover guardians let me know we have a
lot of comics that we need to get caught
up on right like
uh spider-gwen and like guardians of the
galaxy and all kinds of other stuff
i feel like in the face of everything
that's been going on with hickman's
x-men a lot of the other stuff that's
been going on at marvel has kind of been
left to the wayside right we've been
focusing on like thor
we focus on immortal hulk for a little
while uh we had maestro juggernaut
x-men and that was kind of it uh and and
like we kind of left a lot of stuff on
the wayside so
let me know if you guys want me to cover
um anything else we'll probably dedicate
a day to kind of getting caught back up
on comics
but uh but the important thing to go on
here really the important thing to
explain here is that on the guardians of
the galaxy team as it stands right now
you've got marvel boy you've got uh
hercules you've got richard ryder you've
got some familiar faces but the face
that we're missing here is peter quill
and there's actually a reason for that
but the big takeaway from this
is that in the aftermath of null
invading the main marvel universe and
essentially setting his sights on earth
this led to him spreading his influence
throughout the rest of the universe
itself now we can largely assume that
because
null showed up on earth with celestials
he visited other planets before he came
to earth or the very least just like
sought them out immediately and then
took them out and then showed up on
earth we know earth was like his main
target right because you know the marvel
universe marvel comics
you know the idea here is that with him
having more or less conquered the world
that he looks to be kind of expanding
his fear of influence out more and more
and the way to do this and really the
smartest way to do this is to go after
the home worlds of the various races
that exist
out there right the powerhouse races
those of you guys who don't know in
marvel comics when it comes to their
cosmic landscape
you have like maybe four or five
different races that are kind of above
everybody else right i mean you've got
all kinds of races out there right you
got hundreds of thousands of different
races that are out there uh if not
millions or trillions or or
whatever but you only have like empires
right like a handful of empires right so
you've got the badoon
who are basically really great at making
guns you've got the shiar which are an
amalgamation of different races that
have all sworn loyalty to the shiar
empire
you've got the cree race you got the
scroll race you've got the human race on
on earth but you've got different
different groups out there that function
in different purposes
and what null seems to have been doing
is going after these various empires and
we find this out from a couple of
different things
the first is that where richard ryder
kind of looks to hercules and is like
do you know of any god like this right
like you're familiar with gods and the
response of hercules is never heard of
him
i've got no idea who this guy is right
so they're kind of left to their own
they end up switching over to super
scroll right now super scroll
is a scroll that basically has the
powers of the fantastic four he was
irrelevant for
decades and when i say decades i mean
decades and decades and decades
it wasn't really until hickman took over
fantastic four that he became relevant
again but he was important back during
the days of like roy thomas and john
byrne when they were doing fantastic
four but beyond that
he just hadn't really been an important
character but one of the big things that
we kind of learned here
is that the the creek scroll alliance
world right so presumably
the base fight which they're both
operating out of what essentially went
dark some period ago and they haven't
really heard anything from them
you know nothing gets in nothing gets
out and so presumably you ended up
having null who conquered that world
not only that they're basically
following his dragons that we've seen on
earth but seem to be
capable of traveling through space only
for us to find out that they're heading
towards spartax and the way we find this
is we end up being met by the arrival of
victoria
the sister of peter quill and the
daughter of jason so victoria was
introduced to marvel comics back with
legendary star lord number one back in
2014
and while she is the sister of peter
quill and the daughter of jason
she's not really legitimate right she's
the illegitimate daughter of jason of
spartax but she was introduced as a
possible heir or at least somebody who
could basically step closer in line with
the with the royal family with the
the empirical family itself she was of
course sent off to basically prove her
worth the kind of things you would
expect for somebody who showed up and
said hey i'm your daughter you know that
that kind of thing uh but in the
aftermath of the
the event whereby jason the of spartax
was frozen in amber
in a fight between carol danvers jason
and and thane
as well as uh the well the events that
led to peter quill being
basically missing in action which we'll
cover here in a little bit she ended up
becoming the empress right the person
who's currently ruling
the planet of spartax in in his stead
now again we can cover that stuff
i feel like that kind of thing needs a
little more explanation that that
we really you know more than we really
have time for here uh but we can cover
it in videos if you guys are interested
just let me know down in the comment
section
but uh she basically comes running and
says yes like the forces of null
are basically showing up on spartax and
so what we end up doing is picking up on
that planet about four standard hours
later and what you have is just a
massive evacuation right you've got nine
billion people on this planet and
they're just evacuating them as best
they can and the reason why is it really
seems to kind of happen off panel
between the pages
and it really kind of seems to come by
way of moon dragon herself right of
heather douglas
the daughter of drax a long-standing
member of marvel comics those of you
guys who've been reading mobile comments
for a long time
you know exactly who she is those of you
guys who've never heard of moon dragon
one i can almost guarantee we're gonna
see her in the marvel cinematic universe
and two she's the daughter of drax
before drax became drax right back when
he was just
a regular human when he was a normal
human being his name was arthur
ultimately he was he was killed
alongside his wife and then heather was
basically taken
by the the father of thanos and her
telepathic abilities were developed but
what they also seem to have picked up on
is that the forces of null are not
something that's easily overcome right
you don't just show up on a world where
null is currently
you know laying it you know kind of
attacking and then have like some battle
cruisers and fire some shots
and like the day saves six hours later
doesn't really work that way
right it's just one of these things
where he's effectively just like
conquering this world as fast
as he can because he's got this dragon
flying around up there and the dragon
just keeps dropping these giant piles of
goo which in turn
infect the planet very similar to what
we saw on earth at the very beginning of
the king and black event the big
takeaway from this though is that
initially
uh where you end up having having
heather hit up by nova and kind of
asking like
like where are we at how are we doing uh
you know heather's response is we're at
two billion and he's like two billion
evacuated that's not enough she's like
no no no we've evacuated thirty thousand
two billion are dead right people are
dying fast they're dying so incredibly
quickly
and that's what's so insane about this
is you you know it's one of these things
you kind of have to put it into
perspective when you look at the idea of
what's going on here just in this little
tidbit of a story that we're seeing
in relation to like a lot of the other
events that have gone that are going on
the king and black event is huge
right do i think that it's going to
stand the test of time as being an event
that's as grandiose in scale as like
annihilation or annihilation conquest
no because those stories just felt
different right there was just a feeling
that dan abner brought to those stories
that just
nobody else could really duplicate right
i mean it just it felt like it was a
space-faring escapade
this feels like it's an earth-based
event that happens to involve the rest
of space right so it's just a totally
different feeling that goes on but the
long and short of this
is that there's not really much they can
do here except try to keep evacuating as
best as they possibly can
the other part of that is you've got
rocket racoon who kind of chimes in and
it's like look we're doing what we can
but there's only so much we can do here
we just got to get people out of here as
fast as we can but then suddenly like a
few minutes later
you effectively got this kind of portal
that opens up this kind of screaming
sound this portal that opens up rocket
raccoon sniffs and realizes it's peter
quill and when he races over to him he
actually finds peter standing there now
this isn't a little bit of expedition to
go on here right because we don't really
get much explanation in the way
of where pewter's been over the course
of this story right that what you get
here
is like rocket raccoon like damn man i
thought you were dead and everybody's
like yeah man like i thought you were
dead like oh my god i can't believe
you're alive and he basically takes his
element gun which is capable of firing
what or what are in effect the various
elements he shoots at the dragon and
then just
fires off this colossal amount of energy
it's not enough to destroy the dragon
but it's certainly enough to get his
attention
now the reason why why this is happening
and the reason why this matters is
because
prior to the events leading up to this
you had the return of the olympian gods
right but the olympian god showing up
here
it basically led to them kind of going
on a like a mad spree throughout the
universe right and so what it led to
was peter the guardians various people
showing up and essentially confronting
the olympians but in the process
peter basically stayed behind to kind of
detonate this bomb but had an effect
been yanked over to a different
dimension and the result was that he
spent about 180 years
inside that dimension living out a life
with some friends that he made and so
he's kind of
jumped back here now so as far as his
mind is aware as far as his mind
functions
he's he's been alive for 180 years which
means it's 180 years worth of memories
and so that's why it's very easy to
forget things and that's why he doesn't
really remember i mean he remembers like
rocket raccoon
and the other guardians but it takes a
little while for his memory to kind of
rejog itself right because it's like hey
what's going on where's your writer i
haven't seen you in like 180 years right
i mean it's it's
you know i mean i let me tell you
something guys i have a hard time
telling you what i ate two weeks ago let
look i can't even tell you what i have
for dinner last tuesday right like
imagine 180 years passing i mean i know
you guys are the same way right don't
don't lie right don't somebody in the
comments is gonna be like i always
remember what i eat right it's probably
gonna end up being you know one of you
guys who asked who who like asks for
videos all the time because i've seen
those requests about empty hand don't
think i haven't noticed
i've seen those requests y'all i know
how you guys are see now
now that we made that video for for for
wilder
because you just wouldn't stop asking
for it now you guys are just like
batching up in groups
of like 10 or 15 people and like
requesting something
and then all of you like that person's
request and so like now i have to do it
y'all ain't fooling anybody right y'all
y'all can't pull the wool over my eyes i
know how y'all are teaming up i know
what y'all are doing now
but uh but nonetheless you know it's one
of these these cool little things
because it takes a little bit of kind of
re-jogging and sort of sort of bringing
him back
i mean the reality of this is even when
you have uh heather douglas who shows up
here it's kind of like wow this is kind
of wild but then she starts to kind of
tap
into and connect to null to a degree now
she doesn't do it directly
she does it by way of the dragon which
is kind of an agent of null trying to
telepathically link her mind with null
directly would be complete disaster
she'd be totally overwhelmed and
probably just put in a catatonic state
or just outright killed
but the reason why star-lord's gun is
able to fire in this way where it
previously never could
is because the gun is effectively
powered by the energy of the olympian
god ready to kind of siphon that energy
off and now it fires out through his gun
what it also does is it allows him to
become the true star-lord this is really
just marvel comics blending the existing
star-lord mythos with the way it
originally functioned
way back when he was first introduced in
the old black and white comics uh that's
really all that is right
that's really all that's happening here
it's expanding the mythos right and
probably bringing closer in line with
the mcu because we'll probably end up
seeing star-lord using more of like his
quote-unquote celestial power that we
saw in like guardians of the galaxy 2
which was i don't think was a very good
plot point
what uh but unless you know that's kind
of what's what it is that's going on now
and so that's why when they say okay we
need to take this attack directly to
this dragon they're able to do that and
they basically end up penetrating its
hide using the weapon of
of star-lord and effectively break
inside of it right they actually enter
inside this thing
and when they do we see exactly what we
would expect which is a facsimile of
null
and that's one of the ways in which this
guy functions that null seems to kind of
function off and on it's not an
absolute it's not a hard and fast rule
like universally across the board it
works this way no matter what but what
he seems to do here is take kind of a
portion of his own essence and put it
into these individual dragons or what
have you and then that essence of
himself just kind of controls it right
kind of flies around
does its bidding that kind of a thing
and functions accordingly the more
direct explanation here
is that entering into the dragon is kind
of entering into the quote-unquote
spirit of null right so kind of almost
this sort of ethereal trip where you
sort of transcend
the physical form and you kind of
communicate with null directly the
important thing here
is that if null in his real and true
tangible form was here this fight would
be over in an
instant it would it would be over so
fast it wouldn't even last and that's
one of the crazy things is because with
the power that peter quill now has being
able to channel the energy of the
olympian gods and in effect becoming a
god himself
that draws the attention of null right
peter is nowhere near the same level
that null is
but it is a level of power that null can
acquire and boost his power accordingly
because we know that in this this
current form that he's in
nola is almost kind of like a collector
of powerful beings right and it makes
sense if you're a person looking to
conquer the universe you want the most
powerful allies you can get to your side
we've seen that time and time again
in marvel comics onslaught did it with
x-men nate gray and franklin richards
back in the 90s we've seen thanos do it
with various people
when he had like the black order to his
side and all that kind of stuff we've
seen apocalypse do it when he ensnares
various people to become his four
horsemen you see it over and over and
over again in marvel right the big
difference here
is that when peter quill basically
really comes into contact with
null for the very first time that
there's this kind of desire
to basically conquer him right to kind
of take over him and in fact he
almost takes over the entirety of the
guardians of the galaxy team
ensnares them all heather douglas uh
richard ryder every single one of them
and even goes on as to say like you guys
will lose everything like you will
become part of my horde you'll become
part of my forces and you will fight on
my behalf but the person he's not able
to overcome
is star-lord powered by this kind of
star-lord-based energy which we don't
really still have a full explanation on
he's literally powered by what he calls
the master of the sun like that's kind
of what he refers to himself as
but he kind of presents himself as the
antithesis to null
which is a cool concept is it's kind of
interesting i imagine we might see
something done with that later i largely
believe the defeat will of noah will
come down to like eddie brock and venom
because it is a venom based story so it
makes the most sense that's what would
happen that eddie brock would like get
his symbiote back or something along
those lines would happen
uh it i'm kind of curious i mean i don't
really even know yeah
i can't even really ballpark how this is
gonna end it's one of the cool things
about donnie kate's ideas he just throws
in curves
curveballs everywhere right so you're
like i've got this figured out and
donnie case is like no you don't either
because here's the new thing that
happened and it's like what like
it's kind of bonkers in that way right
but because of the power that he
possesses and his his elemental gun
he's able to basically break free of of
null and that's really one of the
only times we've seen that right that
we've seen somebody break free of
knoll's influence
and then actually fire this elemental
gun in the heart of the dragon
and destroy it entirely right so this is
the first the first real offensive move
that we've seen anybody pull off during
the events of the king and black it's
the first time that somebody has managed
to defeat some aspect of null it's new
territory and it's cool to see that's
why i say it's kind of a
big deal and it's something that we
might end up seeing more of the problem
with this
is that they ultimately try to get peter
quill to stay but his answer is i can't
right that's not going to happen and
when they ask him why he says because i
essentially stole the power of the
olympian gods
and because i stole their power because
i killed hephaestus in the process
because i have their their energy and
their power now they're gonna be coming
for it right they're coming back
and they're coming for me and so i have
to go back to this dimension that i was
at and effectively save my friends it's
a cool it's a cool idea what's going on
in guardians of the galaxy right now is
actually amazing from the from from what
i've skimmed and what i've seen again i
haven't really read it with any real
measure of seriousness it looks cool and
it makes sense because al ewing's the
one writing it right al ewing is just
kind of a wizard when it comes to comic
books sometimes what he does doesn't
really make sense in the beginning but
give it enough time and it will
uh the guys the guy's kind of nuts right
but it's a cool little it's a cool
little tidbit here right i mean the big
takeaway is that one
peter quill is basically in a god state
at the moment and then
two uh he's the first person to
successfully overpower null so i mean
what do we do here we give everybody the
power of god there we go
story over with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the raw before if you
guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign